- IT'S SO RICH
IN HISTORY.
- I GREW UP IN A NEIGHBORHOOD
LIKE THIS.
- OH, YEAH, I GREW UP
IN A NEIGHBORHOOD
EXACTLY LIKE THIS.
- ALL RIGHT,
WELCOME TO MAMA SUGARBACK'S.
Y'ALL READY TO ORDER?
- YEAH.
CAN I HAVE A CHICKEN FRIED STEAK
WITH GRAVY AND A COLA?
- OKAY.
- I WILL HAVE THE BAKED BEEF
SHORT RIBS WITH COLLARD GREENS,
AND THROW DOWN
SOME OF THAT CORNBREAD.
- ALL RIGHT, BABE.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
HOLD UP A SECOND.
I'M ALSO GONNA HAVE
SOME OF THEM
COLLARD GREENS AND CORNBREAD
AS WELL,
BUT HOOK A BROTHER UP
WITH SOME OF THEM HOT LINKS.
- ALL RIGHT.
- [chuckles] YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHY AM I TRYING TO FRONT?
SCRATCH ALL THAT.
GIVE ME SOME OKRA
AND SOME FRIED RED SNAPPER.
AND GIRL, YOU KNOW I WANT
SOME CHITLINS.
- ALL RIGHT NOW.
- Y'ALL GOT HAM HOCKS?
- OF COURSE.
- WELL, THAT'S WHAT I WANT.
I WANT A PLATE OF HAM HOCKS,
DEEP-FRIED, BLACKENED,
AND SERVED ON A BED
OF MUSTARD GREENS.
- PIG FEET.
I WANT SOME PIG FEET
AND FOUR POUNDS OF GRITS.
AND OH, OH!
AND YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE?
GIVE ME A LITTLE DIXIE CUP
FULL OF LARD, ALL RIGHT?
- I JUST REMEMBERED WHAT I WANT.
A BOWL OF MOSQUITOES.
NONE OF THEM TINY ONES EITHER,
GIVE ME THEM BIG MOTHER[bleep]
YOU FIND
DOWN AT THE SWAMPS.
- SISTER, COULD YOU PLEASE
HOOK A BROTHER UP
WITH A RUSTY BUCKET
FULL OF FISH HEADS
WRAPPED IN RAZOR WIRE?
- DONKEY TEETH.
- DONKEY TEETH?
- STRAIGHT OUT
A DONKEY'S MOUTH.
YOU KNOW WHAT? [bleep] IT.
ANY ANIMAL TOOTH WILL DO.
I WANT YOU TO STICK IT
IN SOME HONEY GLAZE,
FRY IT WITH FAT BACK,
AND SERVE IT
IN AN OLD TIN COFFEE CAN.
- FORGET EVERYTHING I SAID
UP TO THIS POINT RIGHT NOW.
BRING ME SOME DANDELION GREENS,
A COW HIP, AND A DOG FACE.
WRAP THAT WHOLE MESS
IN AN OLD EBONY MAGAZINE,
AND SERVE IT TO ME
IN A SHOEBOX.
- OKAY, I WANT A PLATTER
OF STORK ANKLES,
AN OLD CELLAR DOOR,
A POSSUM SPINE,
AND A HUMAN FOOT.
- YOU WANT A HUMAN FOOT?
- MM-HMM.
- I GOT JUST ONE QUESTION
FOR Y'ALL.
- YOU WANT GRAVY
ON THAT CELLAR DOOR?
- OH, DEFINITELY.
- OH, YEAH, YEAH.
YOU GOTTA PUT GRAVY ON THAT.
- WHAT'S A CELLAR DOOR
WITHOUT GRAVY?
- IT'S NOT FOOD.
- MMM.
- IT'S REALLY--
[chokes]
- UGH.